talk about sorry well we talked about
this particular example file servers and
files that are on them we can be a
little more specific so let's talk about
the file right okay i'm going to give
you several levels of access to
different files I don't you think about
the differences between them and why
someone might be able to use have one
but not the other ok so I'm going to
start from least access and go to most
access okay so what do you think is the
least kind of access that a user might
have or an account might have to a
particular file on a network the least
amount of access I'm going to put you at
number two what might be less access
than view yeah well I'm going to call
that I'm going to call that view still
yeah and no access which I know it
doesn't seem like it's like what's the
least amount of Rights you could have no
rights okay I'm persona non grata on
this network now this is actually really
important isn't it actually I would say
on any given Network the vast majority
of files you have no access to write
because they belong to other people so
this is not to be forgotten okay no
access now again as I go through and
describe these I want you to think about
which particular cases are you going to
want to have a particular level assigned
to a particular person so here is my
first explanation sometimes files
balloons or other people right so you
don't want others tax system can anyone
think of any other examples of where you
want people to not have access to a file
sad again Ezra part passwords hospitals
I'm going to suggest that's right that's
a good example but it's really the same
reasons before that those passwords
belong to someone else right no not
really ah ok yep no right so let's think
about this right I if I let's see what
this computer will do even when you're
not on network ok um just thinking about
your own local hard drive ok your
computer will try to give you no access
to some of the files on there so let's
just experiment let's just see what I
can get if I go windows let's try in oh
yeah that's interesting I have power ok
yeah oh yeah ok never usually ok now at
this point and you can experiment on
your own computers I'd expect that your
laptops would be a little a little more
stringent ok where I am if you can't see
this one ah that's more interesting
there we go ok so um if you didn't catch
where I was going I'm in the windows
folder ok show the operating system and
I've gone all the way down to system now
a former like system you would assume
has you know important essential stuff
in it but apparently this folder is
empty how mysterious and to be like
opening up the bonnet of your car and
it's just like a hole it's like where's
my engine um ok no it's not really empty
is it like you don't know need to know
that much about a car to know it should
have an engine in there and you don't
even know much our windows to think
there should be something in this folder
ok so what's going on um i have no
access to this now it's not to do with
me not owning those files in a sense i
do earn those files on this computer why
can't i access them jack
right okay to stop me from you know
setting fire to my own house and
destroying it okay so um no taxes is
often not just for privacy reasons for
confidentiality but just to protect the
user just to protect the user from
damaging their own system okay all right
next up is view okay so what would view
imply it means like we saw well where
the cup here is like we sort of this
fall huh I can actually look at things
okay but let's see if I let's let's take
a file like hmm I wonder what this does
ok this is risky isn't it okay perfect
you all right now so I'm in the system32
folder okay which by the way if you're
curious it's similar to the system
folder but I think we're wearing windows
7 which is mainly 64-bit ok so the core
system files aren't aren't 32-bit
doesn't matter if you don't know the
distinction between this but anyway I
just tried to delete this file I just
hit delete ok and it said you will need
to provide administrative permission to
delete this file ok so i can see that
the file is there so i could view it but
it's not letting me muck around with her
right wisely so ok only the
administrator can do something like this
if i say skip I just oh you don't get
all askme don't with indicate I guess
continue BAM they go ok so you can see
um this is all of this permission
actually built into the system ok so
I'll say to continue no I'm not going to
continue let's try that when the file go
is it gone not still there it recycled
but did this I wonder why you told me
that it's like I just trying to fool you
it's like yeah sure you you deleted it
anyway ok so view what would you expect
is the next one oh by the way sorry view
is also also called read ok it's like
you can open a book and read it ok
okay now what would come next come sail
yeah download okay so be able to grab it
copier to your own computer I'm going to
suggest yes that is an important
permission I think it's kind of part of
this one right because on a computer
which is different to like say if you're
in in barnes and noble or dim it to
whatever and you read a book that's
different to them taking the book home
right that's different level of mission
but on a computer right once you're
reading something you've actually
already got it because reading is taking
a copy of it putting it in your RAM that
kind of thing okay so viewing reading on
a network is the same as taking a copy
on okay what comes next I'm going to
suggest the next one is called modify
modify okay so this means not only can i
open up files but I can actually change
their contents you can actually change
their contents so this is a processing
issue yes here I can have a look but I
can't actually do any alterations
okay now the next one people will get
confused between three and four because
they sound very similar for the next
level up is called right now hold on a
second did it like right you know as in
my change stuff isn't that the same as
modify hmm what would you think is the
difference in modifier and right if you
could distinguish between them what I
fire versus right um yeah Sonny hmm ok
so if you've got two filed it right I'm
monkey around with the things that are
inside it I'm going to suggest that
that's what modify means okay some want
to go further yet ah ok so let's let's
go after this I think we're on the right
track in when I say can you modify this
ok that kind of implies there's
something already there and you just
make some changes to it ok but right
doesn't assume that ok if I say hey can
you write me an essay they might have
been no sa there before ok so right is
kind of a little bit like create ok can
you put new things on here ok um can you
make something where there wasn't
anything before so that's us it's a
slight distinction but an important one
ok
all right that leads us to our last
highest level of access or fire
privileges which is called full control
now hmm I wonder if you've been thinking
so far writing and creating and editing
files seems like it's pretty good right
that seems like a pretty good level of
arm of access alone with creating you've
got actually the officer which is the
leading it's also something that what if
I can't do but what would fool control
me like what more can you do they create
files change them and delete them yeah
aha so full control right it's what the
administrator can do in terms of
deciding what everyone else can do okay
so full control if you like it's a
little bit like on um when you did your
group project on Google Sites you had
people who were owners versus people who
could edit what's the diff you should
know not an ad editor right the
difference they're getting at is the
difference in four and five full control
means i can say you can do this but not
this and you can do everything or
whatever okay whereas writing creating
anything all that kind of thing is
everything except for actually monthly
around with other people's permissions
ok so i guess all of these are about
content but the thing this last one adds
is editing the actual permissions that
other people have ok